you mentioned that in some of the
circles that you've been in that the
case of bob lazar it isn't as dismissed
as it is in the popular culture and
without what he says comports with
yeah other reports in such a way that it
makes much of his account true or likely
to be true even if certain specifics of
the account isn't yeah can you expound
on that sure so a lot of the people that
i talked to in the you know like who are
like tyler basically um believed lazar
okay which i thought was fascinating
because like he's so
dismissed okay for the most part
but they didn't dismiss him at all and
so i thought that's fascinating um what
did he see did he see actually
extraterrestrials or did he see weapons
or you know what did he see he saw
something that caused
a
you know a huge reaction
and pushback and discrediting of him and
that kind of thing you know to the point
where he said i wish i had never said
anything in the first place right and
basically that's what some of the people
told me just before my book came out
they said there might be a point where
you wish that you didn't do this and so
i'm not like bob lazar in that i'm not
saying this was extraterrestrial right
i'm not saying that i'm saying there's a
development at play and let's pay
attention to it because it first it has
to do with religion
and belief systems but there's something
really strange about it going on and i
think we have to give it you know look
at it but i'm not suggesting that any
kind of
hypothesis about it is true like he did
like we this is extraterrestrial how did
you know
i don't think he said that he actually
was he's extremely careful with his
words he would say i don't know all i
know is that i worked on a craft and
that there were documents given to me
that said they were extraterrestrial but
that could be misinformation right
that's what i do know it operates in
this manner or it seems to operate in
this manner but he was extremely careful
yeah as far as
yeah no he should be definitely that
would be the correct way to go about
doing that kind of thing to be involved
in that is to not conclude and also to
basically because there's been precedent
for mis disinformation you have to
assume that some of it's going to be at
play
especially now
and in fact we have better tools for
disinformation today than we ever did
better tools for
recognizing disinformation or for the
dissemination of it both